kintanji brown jackson grew up in a
middle-class suburb of miami where both
parents worked as school teachers and
where she made a name for herself at
debate competitions by writing her name
kentunji on the chalkboard for all to
see she would have to
um
speak before
largely white audiences and had to sort
of
bridge that gap and convey to them
instantaneously in case there was any
subtle bias or just
lack of familiarity with her just
starting from her name steven rosenthal
was jackson's classmate from an early
age he says he never doubted that one
day his charismatic friend would achieve
these heights so she just drew people
toward her
and
people wanted to support her and um
respected her so she just had
all the tools in addition to being
brilliant
to succeed in whatever she chose to do
jackson has been a federal judge for
nine years and currently sits on the d.c
court of appeals she's issued about 500
opinions but none on the hot button
issues of abortion gun rights and
freedom of religion
she did gain fame in 2019 when she
blocked president trump from shielding
former white house counsel dom again
from testifying before congress writing
presidents are not kings
judge jackson deserves to be confirmed
as the next justice supreme court some
republicans have accused jackson of
being the favored choice of far left
groups but the same senate confirmed her
to her appeals court position a year ago
with support from three republicans
jackson would replace another liberal
stephen breyer the justice she once
clerked for and she would be the first
black woman to join the u.s supreme
court
i can only hope that my life and career
my love of this country and the
constitution
and my commitment to upholding the rule
of law and the sacred principles upon
which this great nation was founded will
inspire future generations
of americans even me when i think about
myself as a as a lawyer i didn't have
many um people to look up to that looked
like i did and so i think for young um
girls to be able to
look at justice jackson and see where
she is and and how far she's come is
really really going to be an important
moment jackson has seen her future
clearly since high school telling a
yearbook editor she wanted to go into
law and eventually have a judicial
appointment
now on the brink of being appointed to
the highest court in the land she's also
serving as inspiration for many
heidi joe castro al jazeera washington